c'est un 11h30 ce matin que monsieur
garret l'ancien propriétaire de ces
lieux a remis les clés du futur parc
public charles iii à la ville de nancy
ce qui a permis aux membres de la
municipalité présent de visiter les
lieux qui seront normalement au
printemps 80 un paradis pour enfants car
la mairie n'a pas hésité par
l'intermédiaire de l'union féminine
civique et sociale à prendre l'avis des
premiers intéressés les utilisateurs des
parcs c'est à dire les enfants eux mêmes
et les enfants des quartiers nous ont
fait des suggestions très intéressante
vous en avez une idée en regardant ce
plan et la dizaine de plants que les
enfants ont élaboré alors qu'est ce que
souhaitent des enfants il souhaite
beaucoup de choses ils soient des
pelouses bien sûr ils souhaitent des
espaces de jeu il souhaite de l'eau
il souhaite d'avoir des terrains
différencié pour qu' il ne gêne pas les
personnes qui veulent se reposer
il souhaite même un gardien pour entrer
à leur une idée d'enfants par exemple
qui nous a été suggérée et que nous
n'aurions pas eu c'est de créer un
embryon de forêt parce que ils ont
indiqué qu'ils voulaient avoir un espace
pour jouer à cache-cache pour ce faire
des jeux de poursuites et c'est une
chose est sûre les enfants veulent
s'amuser sans saccagé à cet effet il
sera mis à leur disposition différents
secteurs une partie jeux d'enfants
organisé une autre réservée à la détente
ainsi qu'une aire de promenade mais tout
cela coûte fort cher et même très cher
c'est pour cela que la municipalité a
prévu les acquisitions en deux temps
ainsi que les travaux coût total environ
4 millions de francs payée en partie par
la ville elle même aidé de
l'établissement public financier de
lorraine qui sera propriétaire d'une
partie des lieux et de plus non s'ils
espèrent aussi obtenir une subvention du
ministère de l'environnement
je crois qu'il faut pas toujours
s'arrêter aux questions d'argent pour
rééquilibrer une ville et répondent aux
besoins des habitants
alors notre intention est d'aller très
vite de préparer maintenant le projet
définitif l'appel taf de commencer les
mouvements de terre
dès l'automne les plantations dès cet
hiver et de mettre la première tranche
en service dès le printemps 1981 dès le
printemps d'année prochaine
c'est donc avec les premiers rayons de
soleil du printemps 80 que les petits
habitants du quartier charles iii
pourront avoir de l'air pour se rouler
de l'eau pour patauger une horloge pour
rentrer à leur est aussi selon leurs
desiderata un gardien pour les aider à
respecter les lieux